i don't trust people that have dead
animals on their wall that's
rule number one of living club you feel
me like if i go into a house
and they got dead animals all over the
wall you got problems really
yeah man have you been to joe rogan's
house
i can imagine he has dead animals dead
comedians
he probably has tony hinchcliffe up
there
did you all talk about hinchcliffe on
you guys a show on tfa tkz
yeah did you no we uh we didn't talk
about it yesterday we didn't know about
it yesterday i don't think or yeah i
don't know when it happened no just
where were you at on it i mean i just
there shouldn't be cell phones recording
anybody's
first of all i just don't know that's a
safe place and then
the problem too is i talked to comics
who
tore with derrick i'm sorry i talked
with comics who tore with tony
and some other guys who were there and
they're like dude he's been
he's been doing that that set like
that's that's part of his set for
weeks man it crushes yeah and someone
decides to cut it so
if you just see that yeah it looks
terrible he's like but if you see the
whole thing
it's really good yeah if you don't like
i'll admit like when you first see like
jesus christ tony
but also you're supposed to be in a safe
zone comedy zone i know a lot of guys
they start recording sets like that and
blasting out people can get in trouble
man
that's not what they are yeah i'm sure
if you took some of my lines and just
put them out there random like that like
yeah if it was real blunt you don't know
the context and you just put oh theo
said this but you're not in a
comedy venue or anything like that like
that's not that's not the right thing to
do
yeah and also that comic who did it to
him you know he's opened up
for him a number of times also posted
how thankfully it was for tony it's like
depending how he feels you know again
this is me going based off tony has done
this previously so you knew he was gonna
do this and then now you do it
and put hashtag you know asian pride
week or whatever
uh he's seen clout chase yeah this i
tweeted yesterday snitch clout comedy is
a new thing apparently
and i don't know if i really i just felt
like it just felt
like look man we've all people say
things it's wrong sometimes or it's
right to you or whatever i think you
take it up with that person
tony's also remember this tony's roaster
he's a roaster like he said some
horrible [ __ ] to me
like it's it's if you ever seen kill
tony like he lights people up dude oh if
you've ever seen the first 60 episodes
of this show i've said some horrible
[ __ ] to you
yeah but it's like uh i'm not gonna
record him like look at field bully me
but no i you know i just felt like i
just don't like the way i wish i just
don't like the route we're going i wish
it had a different
i wish there were some different punch
lines in it for sure that would have
like at least like kind of
seem like it made it more entertaining
but then i think that's
but that's a i don't mean to rip you but
that's the point i think if it would
have been more
funny that you know he would get more
backing online but when you just see
that clip even i
like i saw it actually it was terrible
yeah like what's your stance on it chin
as an asian american i just thought it
wasn't funny so if it was funny
it'd probably be different right i agree
and i'm not i'm not
i'm not going to say that tony's the
funniest guy in the world to me right
but i will say that his thing is saying
abusive
and messed up [ __ ] is being mean dude a
lot of times that's in some of the same
vain as hari shafir and some of that
world you know
actually it's they're different but uh
no you're on the right path like it's
that
it's that it's that type of comedy like
tony is a savage and like
he go you know he goes below the belt
that's just what he does right and
sometimes when you're saying me
like messed up [ __ ] it's not it's
there's no plan for it
it's also not for everybody like that
wasn't supposed to be blasted to the
masses like that's his
tight-knit group yeah so i just felt
like yeah it just felt like kind of
clout chasey a little bit to me at the
end no it's no different those girls on
raya posting with the celebrities like
they're not doing that because they're
upset that [ __ ] ben affleck
dm'd them they're they're just trying to
get clout well that's what this comment
is i don't know
well i don't know maybe tony had been
rude also to the guy i wonder if there
was something else that happened that
made him feel
yeah to do this like maybe he was doing
and maybe he said something
again i have no [ __ ] clue so i'm
talking my ass there but maybe he was
like hey man
i don't like that that hurts my feelings
please don't do that again tony's like
what went on stage it again he's like
all right dude i told you
yeah so maybe there's that but even that
just as a comic like
there's code man you don't snitch on
each other and now tony's lost
his representation he can't perform
there anymore
where he does kill tony the venue won't
let them allow them anymore so
wow there's repercussions this these
days yeah
i haven't heard the opener talk was it a
good impression
i don't know i'm just kidding i'm just
kidding that's a good question
oh i don't even know jim we didn't get
your thoughts off i feel bad i'll cut
you off up there
on the giant on the uh asian comedian
thing yeah it wasn't
it just didn't feel funny yeah i told
brandon until i was like it just wasn't
funny yeah
if it was funny it'd be different it was
like easy jokes like soy sauce like what
the hell
yeah what do you what do you think
should happen to him chin yeah
i think everyone deserves a chance would
you say everyone deserves a chance
he [ __ ] up you saying a second chance
yeah what do you think about the guy
filming him and putting it out
that's what i told brent too i was like
that's the thing i thought was the worst
that guy filming like
leave that in there and plus tony might
be working out the joke we don't know
so right yeah they said i talked to
other comedians down there in austin
like dude he's been
doing it before and you're crashing with
it he's like trying to figure it out
but also some there's people there's
there's there's there's and there's all
types of entertainment
so it's like some entertainment is crass
messed up stuff pornography compared to
ballet you know they're both like uses
of the body
to do things and one of them is
extremely vulgar and messed up and one
of them is
more artistic to some but other people
see it here but here's the thing
like if i'm into that type of whatever
ballet i'll watch it if i don't like
that porn i don't have to watch it you
don't have to buy tickets to watch 20
inch clip right you do where the [ __ ] he
wants
yeah maybe it's not for you but to lose
gigs over it
because he has a fan base some people
dig it
[Music]